je n'ai pas besoin tout face va tout
face à face
alors ça pollue à l'arrière l'arrière
complètement c'est pas bercy tient du
tout
je le vois comme donc on n'est pas aussi
je rendais au dessus non attendez c'est
pas le droit à gauche moi le foot en
vertical en ce moment il n'est pas grave
quand il est comme ça fait sale arrière
dépassement la rigolade ou pas du tout
aux endroits mais au dessus et c'est
passé récent
oh
la pole est complètement derrière à
l'arrière de votre
père ne regarde pas que la gauche n'a
pas peut-être eu un truc regarde de plus
on est comme ça
alors on reprend dans le sens
du jour dont quatre ans et demi atteints
or la mort violente
à la moi je vois plus rien at what were
voit la super super super super lap et
en date étant complètement qui suivent
noir perd la boule et voilà c'est pour
ça que je trouvais apicale j'vais pas
trop verticalement tu vois
certains voient là c'est bon c'est un
peu un endroit et la merde là on est
trop à droite trop à droite ou
pas
alors on va était alors les parois
verticales alarme et vertical voilà
enfin comme ça pour voir ce pont je
crois qu'ils se trouvent les failles
classique arabe et histoire
parce qu'on voit plus rien -
version la troïka remettrait un fardeau
l'église
hop
ça va sentir pour la part à la bombe
d'oslo les ikastola
mais enfin
au loin ou pas